page en france n'en finit pas
d'augmenter et aujourd'hui trois
millions cinq cent trente six mille
français se trouvent sans activité c'est
un triste record pour notre pays et cela
malgré l'euro faible malgré la politique
accommodante de la banque centrale
européenne malgré le faible prix du
pétrole malgré les prémices de reprise
or nous sommes nombreux à avoir la
conviction que les entreprises
détiennent la clé de l'emploi et de la
croissance sur notre territoire
c'est pourquoi le président gérard
larcher a proposé au bureau du sénat à
la fin de l'année dernière de créer une
délégation aux entreprises cette
délégation que j'ai l'honneur de
présider et chargé précisément de
recenser les obstacles au développement
des entreprises et de proposer des
mesures il on a simplifié les normes
applicables à l'activité économique
et c'est à cette fin que les sénateurs
de la délégation vont à la rencontre des
entrepreneurs depuis maintenant six mois
dans les différents départements dans
lesquels nous nous sommes rendus nous
avons écouté une centaine d'entre eux à
la tête d'entreprises de tailles petites
moyennes ou intermédiaires qui font
vivre nos territoires
tous nous ont alertés sur le poids de la
réglementation et sur l'énergie qu'ils
doivent s'y consacrer au détriment des
projets d'avenir pour leur entreprise
alors je ne pourrais pas rapporter ici
la richesse de nos échanges eux ni les
nuances locales mais il me semble
important de indiqué monsieur le
ministre
l'élément clé qui en ressort ce que nous
avons essentiellement entendu des
entrepreneurs c'est laissez nous
travailler
en effet la complexité des règles à
appliquer conjuguée à leur instabilité
prend un temps considérable entreprises
20 à 30% nous indiquer un entrepreneur
de la drôme est les normes sont trop
nombreuses dans tous les domaines dans
le domaine social d'abord le code du
travail
on le sait est particulièrement épais en
france une entreprise nous a indiqué que
l' embauche du 50e salariés entraînait
tellement d'obligations qu'il fallait
même prévoir en bouche d'un 51e pour
tout gérer une autre a pointé la
lourdeur de la déclaration obligatoire
d'emploi des travailleurs handicapés
toutes dénoncent aussi la complexité du
conte pénibilité dans le domaine de la
construction également les normes sont
pile au nom du principe de précaution la
prévention des risques technologiques
les normes antisismiques la protection
de l'environnement et en matière fiscale
le maquis réglementaire est telle que
beaucoup d'entreprises appellent de
leurs voeux une généralisation du
rescrit la complexité de la transmission
d'entreprises nous a été également
souvent rapporté une entreprise
familiale nous est dit songer à monter
une holding pour faciliter sa
transmission
cette prolifération de normes soulève
des questions juridiques
mais je tiens ici à souligner que c'est
aussi un sujet économique majeur non
seulement ces normes engendre des coûts
élevés qu'en été estimés à 60 milliards
d'euros par la commission attali et
c'était en 2008 mais elle pèse également
sur l'attractivité de notre pays nos
collègues alain lambert et jean claude
boulard l'avait d'ailleurs dénoncé dans
un rapport percutant qui a été remis en
mars 2013 au premier ministre jean marc
ayrault
le gouvernement en a pris acte c'est
ainsi que le premier ministre a adressé
le 17 juillet 2013 une circulaire aux
membres du gouvernement les invitant à
geler la réglementation ce texte prévoit
notamment que toute norme créé doit
s'accompagner d'une simplification
équivalente ce système de gages vise à
la fois les collectivités territoriales
et les entreprises
ce sont ces dernières qui préoccupe
naturellement notre délégation
et c'est pourquoi nous souhaiterions
vous demandez aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre de nous présenter le bilan
d'application de cette circulaire dont
je ne suis pas tout à fait certaine que
les entreprises ressentent
à ce jour les effets ainsi quelle
méthodologie le gouvernement suit il
pour mettre en application cette règle
chaque ministre at il recensé les textes
applicables dans son champ de compétence
évalué le coût de ces normes
repérez les dispositions obsolètes ou
inutiles susceptibles d'être supprimés
comment sont précisément évalué les
charges
8 pour les entreprises par chaque
dispositions existantes ou envisagées
avec quels outils et il vérifié normes
pour normes que la réduction de charges
permises par la suppression de l'une
compense l'augmentation de charges
résultant de l'adoption de l'autre ce
travail at il effectué à une échelle
consolidé par ministère ou à l'échelle
de l'ensemble de notre corpus juridique
bref comment le secrétariat général du
gouvernement
supervise t-il la mise en oeuvre de la
circulaire les administrations centrales
comme déconcentré sont-elles
responsabiliser mobilisées pour
atteindre cet objectif
surtout pouvez vous nous dire dans
quelle mesure il a été atteint vous
n'ignorez pas monsieur le ministre
d'autres grands pays européens peuvent
inspirer notre action en ce domaine
ainsi l'allemagne à son norman contrôle
rate organe indépendant créé en 2006 par
le gouvernement pour réduire la
bureaucratie et qui offre une évaluation
précise et transparente de la charge
induite pour toutes nouvelles
dispositions avant son adoption
de même le royaume uni à son régulateur
y policy committee
créé en 2009 est chargé de vérifier les
estimations des coûts et bénéfices en
terme économique social et
environnemental de chaque norme
envisager cet organe accompagne le
gouvernement dans l'application de la
règle qu'il s'est fixée pour réduire le
poids des normes
le conseil de la simplification pour les
entreprises d'avril 2014 avait
d'ailleurs préconisée en priorité la
création d'un organe équivalent pour la
france vous avez annoncé la semaine
dernière sa mise en place au 1er juillet
pourrait vous nous le confirme et
monsieur le ministre la règle
britannique ressembler au départ à
celles fixées dans la circulaire dont
nous débattons aujourd'hui one in one à
haute
mais le gouvernement britannique a revu
en 2013 son ambition à la hausse avec le
mot d'ordre
one in two à haute une livre sterling de
charge créé par l'adoption d'une
nouvelle norme doit s'accompagner de la
suppression non plus d'une mais de deux
livres sterling de charge existantes et
l'ambition de déflation législatives est
désormais gravé dans le marbre de la loi
en effet lors de notre déplacement à
londres en avril
nous avons appris que le royaume uni
venait d'adopter en mars 2015
une loi relative aux pme et à l'emploi
qui contraint le gouvernement à
respecter sur la durée de la législature
un objectif de simplification
réglementaire destiné à favoriser la
croissance des entreprises
l'enjeu de la prolifération normative
n'est pas seulement quantitatif il
implique une plus profondes évolutions
d'ordre qualitatif
il s'agit d'entrer dans une culture de
résultat cela signifie évaluer les
effets des dispositions applicables en
aval pour éventuellement les réajuster
mais aussi en amont mieux documenter les
études d'impact même si les projets de
loi doivent être assorties d'une étude
d'impact ces études sont souvent trop
légère
le constat a d'ailleurs été récemment
partagé par le conseil d'état dans sa
délibération du 8 décembre 2014 relative
au projet de loi sur la croissance et
l'activité
il n'a pu je le cite que déplorer à la
dette de cette saisine du projet de loi
le caractère lacunaire et les graves
insuffisances de l'étude d'impact sur
nombre de dispositions du projet de loi
la délégation sénatoriale aux
entreprises éprouvent le besoin d'études
ciblées et documenté pour être en mesure
d'assurer correctement sa mission
d'examiner les dispositions des projets
proposition de loi comportant des normes
applicables aux entreprises mission que
lui a confiée le bureau du sénat la
délégation a aussi reçu du bureau du
sénat la mission de proposer des mesures
visant à favoriser l'esprit d'entreprise
et à simplifier les normes applicables à
l'activité économique en vue
d'encourager la croissance et l'emploi
dans les territoires elle a donc
également besoin d'évaluer les
conséquences des mesures proposées par
les entrepreneurs qu'elle rencontre sur
le terrain
c'est pourquoi nous envisageons de
recourir à des études d'impact au cours
des prochaines années
la commission juncker plaide aussi dans
ce sens à l'échelon européen
là monsieur le ministre comment votre
gouvernement entente il prendre sa part
dans cette évolution
permettez moi pour en finir d'aborder la
question du poids des normes pour nos
autres
prise sous un angle plus large de nos
échanges avec les entrepreneurs français
implantés dans nos territoires il
ressort que les normes leur pèse tout
autant par leur nombre et leur
instabilité que par l'état d'esprit qui
anime l'administration chargée de leur
application d'abord notre administration
se positionne en contrôleur de
l'application des normes au lieu
d'accompagner ou de conseiller les
entreprises afin qu'elles s'y conforment
partout nous les avons rencontrés les
entrepreneurs nous lance faites nous
confiance depuis quelques mois le
premier ministre déclare dans toutes les
langues qu'ils aiment les entreprises
mais nous avons senti nous une forme de
dépit amoureux chez les entrepreneurs
ils se sentent soupçonné d'emblée ainsi
l'un d'eux a reçu à titre purement
préventif un courrier l'informant que si
d'aventuré son entreprise ne
respectaient pas les 35 heures il
s'exposerait à des poursuites pénales
plusieurs déplorent par exemple qu'on
est les jugent pas assez responsables
pour assurer la sécurité de leurs
apprentis au point de la garantir par
des règles si contraignantes qu'elles
ont deviennent absurdes et paralysante
d'ailleurs le gouvernement a bien été
obligé de les revoir récemment faisons
confiance aux entreprises au lieu de les
présumés coupables
la délégation l'a vu à l'ombre les
entreprises qui ont un pied de chaque
côté de la manche nous font part de la
différence d'approché fondamentale entre
les administrations nationales la
confiance que l'administration
britannique fait aux entreprises libère
les l'entrepreneuriat ce qui n'empêche
pas d'ailleurs de sanctionner sans état
d'âme les cas d'infraction en france
nombre de ceux qui ont sollicité un
crédit impôt recherche par exemple ont
témoigné avoir subi dans la foulée un
contrôle fiscal comme si l'on était
suspecte dès lors qu'on innove ainsi
trop occupé à contrôler plutôt qu'à
accompagner notre administration a trop
souvent tendance à pécher par excès de
zèle
dans l'interprétation qu'elle fait des
normes de nombreuses entreprises sur le
terrain atteste de la concurrence
déloyale qu'ils subissent de la part de
leurs compétiteurs même européens soumis
à des normes moins sévère comment
expliquer cela sinon par une naïveté
européenne dans les négociations
commerciales mais aussi par une sur
transposition française des directives
communautaires
la circulaire dont nous discutons de
l'application avait elle-même identifié
cette difficulté précise puisqu'elle
invite l administration a justifié
expressément toute règles plus
exigeantes imposées par la france lors
pouvez-vous à l'occasion du bilan que
nous en faisons aujourd'hui également
nous dire monsieur le ministre ce qu'il
est advenu de cette mesure que vous avez
annoncé à nouveau la semaine dernière je
crois alors qu'elle figurait déjà dans
la circulaire de 2013 d'ailleurs la
nouvelle commission européenne vient de
proposer dans son paquet mieux légiférer
que chaque état membre opère une claire
distinction entre ce qui est décidé à
bruxelles
et ce qui est ajoutée au niveau national
régional ou local
je voudrais conclure en rappelant que
les entreprises sont le berceau de la
croissance de l'emploi pour nos
territoires il ne suffit pas de les
aimer nous devons tous chercher à leur
simplifier la vie pour leur laisser le
temps de travail et d'innover et leur
permettre d'être plus compétitives nous
devons amener un changement d'état
d'esprit et faire confiance par principe
aux entreprises c'est une dimension
importante de notre combat contre le
chômage les règles les protections
l'énorme certes rassure mais notre
ambition ce n'est pas de nous cramponner
notre enjeu ce n'est pas seulement de
maintenir les emplois c'est d'en créer
donc faisons des normes un facteur de
croissance et de compétitivité pour que
la france tienne une place solide dans
l'économie mondiale je vous remercie
merci beaucoup chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur henri cabanel
pour le groupe socialiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
les entrepreneurs sont unanimes pour
saluer le bien fondé de la création de
liens forts entre les parlementaires et
le monde de l'entreprise
c'est une démarche que j'ai appliqué à
titre personnel dès mon élection en
démarrant un tour des entreprises du
département d'où je vienne l'hérault
pour aller au plus près de la réalité
économique
je remercie notre présidente et
collègues
élise avait de la mûre pour l'animation
de cette délégation d'entreprises
l'action de la délégation s'appuie sur
la rencontre avec des pme et tpe qui
représente 99 8 % des entreprises
françaises et qui emploie 50 % des
salariés
nous sommes ici au plus près des
territoires grâce à nos déplacements sur
le terrain la majorité des entrepreneurs
ont exposé des problématiques
récurrentes sur tous les territoires
le contraire aurait été étonnant d un
contexte de marasme économique très fort
cependant quand l'entrepreneur fait
preuve d'audace et des couteaux dans son
management on peut encore trouver un
français des patrons et des salariés
heureux à valrhona dans la drôme
nous avons été accueilli par une
banderole bienvenue aux sénateurs dans
une entreprise où tout varié
derrière cette phrase est teinté
d'humour il a une démarche de ressources
humaines
84 des bourses d % des salariés sont
heureux de travailler de cette société
classé 11e au classement national
great place to work
évidemment mon objectif n'est pas de
vous faire croire que tout est déjà
réglé dans le pays
nos échanges multiples avec le monde de
l'entreprise nous a permis d'identifier
une véritable soif de simplification
c'est un coup bas porté par notre
gouvernement alors que la majorité
précédente ne devait ces mouvements de
simplification qu'à l'action courageuse
de certaines parlementaires le
gouvernement actuel s'est saisie
pleinement de cette thématique à la
compaction en accompagnant l'action
parlementaire par un secrétariat dédié
et c'est la première fois et je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre pour votre
engagement et votre travail
résultat plus de deux sa mesure de
simplification concernant les
entreprises ont été prises depuis avril
preuve du lien étroit entre l'action
menée par notre gouvernement et les
demandes exprimées par les entreprises
c'était prendre pour exemple les
demandes des entreprises de lire ou que
nous avons visités il répond se
trouvaient dans les annonces récentes du
premier ministre et du secrétaire l'état
concernant la sueur transposition des
normes
effectivement nous sommes dans un pays
où les mots mettre des normes sur des
normes et en tout cas les normes
européennes
une entreprise charcuterie les bras
zerrad nous a ainsi posé le problème du
bisulfite composés chimiques interdits
en france est utilisé dans d'autres pays
d'europe pour une plus longue
conservation des produits vendus ensuite
dans notre pays
cela crée donc une iniquité au niveau de
la concurrence
le gouvernement vient d'annoncer des
mesures très claires entourant les
dispositions françaises alors qu'elles
sont plus contraignantes que les
exigences européennes testées d'abord
les textes européens sur les panels
entreprises mettre en place des
processus d'explication et de
justification obligatoire en cas de sur
13 positions réexaminer les sur 13
positions antérieures dans les mêmes
conditions
concernant l'apprentissage la sica
diverger de mauguio a soulevé la
problématique très connue des escabeaux
cska vont constituer un exemple
caricatural d'une norme sans doute pensé
par des personnes n'ayant jamais vu
d'arbres fruitiers ni de près ni de loin
annoncée par françois rebsamen au sénat
et aux assises de l'apprentissage de
décret important du 17 avril 2015 entre
en vigueur le 2 mai simplifier la
procédure de dérogation aux travaux
interdits avec le premier décret les
jeunes de 15 à 18 ans apprenti contrat
professionnel s'agir élèves étudiants
peuvent désormais utiliser les échelles
escabeau et marchent pieds dans des
conditions prévues par les dispositions
de droit commun du code du travail
l'autre décret entoure le travail la
formation des jeunes munis d'un
équipement de protection individuelle
cet assouplissement cumulée à la prise
en charge par l'état des charges des
jeunes apprentis
la première année de leur contrat vont
favoriser nous l'espérons leur embauche
concernant l'interprétation du cadre
législatif par les services de l'état
au délà des entreprises rencontrées par
la délégation dans l'hérault de nombreux
entrepreneurs d'effets energy la société
khadraoui france m'ont témoigné de
l'interprétation des textes législatifs
par les fonctionnaires d'état notamment
en ce qui concerne les produits que les
projets d'énergie renouvelable là encore
l'enjeu et l'équité le gouvernement
conscient de ce problème de
cloisonnement entre les administrations
regret d'annoncer que les doctrines
nationale seront clairement affichées
pour chaque corps de contrôle dans un
souci de partage de pratiques et de
connaissance en tout transversalité et
décision d'interprétation ne vont être
publiés régulièrement est rendue
facilement accessible à l'ensemble des
entreprises conserver les seuils sociaux
l'entreprise et héraultaises dont on a
voulu évoquer tout à l'heure
certainement notre présidente madame
lamure médithau spécialisée dans la
production et vente de coquillages nous
a expliqué qu'elle allait créer une
autre société pour éviter le passage au
delà des 50 salariés
le gouvernement a annoncé deux mesures
phare la suppression des deux premiers
ce premier seuil pour commencer avec un
seuil de 11 salariés
le gel les prélèvements fiscaux et
sociaux pendant trois ans pour le seuil
des 50 salariés afin de permettre aux
entreprises de s'adapter
ces mesures ont pour objectif encore de
doper les embauches au sein des tpe et
pme comme l'aide de 4000 euros aux tpe
qui embauchent un premier salarié pour
un cdi ou un cdd de plus de 12 mois
concernant l'agriculture lors de notre
visite de la cave coopérative terroir de
la voie domitienne la principale
problématique cité a été la lourdeur
administrative
les réponses du gouvernement sont ils
encore concrètement la dématérialisation
pour de nombreuses formalités
déclaration autorisation de plantation
la mise en place du nom du nouveau titre
d'emploi service avicole tesa qui
permettra une extension importante du
champ des bénéficiaires une majorité de
contrôle sur le lieu de l'exploitation
sera remplacé par des contrôles sur la
base de pièces justificatives
un bémol quand même le souhait des caves
coopératives de faire une seule
déclaration de récolte par entité
au lieu de déclarations individuelles
comme actuellement même si ce chantier
de simplification n'est pas achevée il
faut saluer le travail déjà effectué
notre rôle de parlementaire nous impose
de communiquer sa modération sur ces
nouvelles mesures auprès des
entrepreneurs mais aussi dans quelques
mois de faire le bilan avec eux au
travers peut être dans la délégation aux
entreprises j'espère que dans le cadre
des nouveaux déplacements de la
délégation des bandeaux rôle comme celle
vue dans la brume bienvenue à une
entreprise où tout va bien sûr on plus
courante cela signifiera que le travail
a été nécessaire et qu'il aura porté ses
fruits je vous remercie
merci cher collègue monsieur dominique
watrin vous avez la parole pour le
groupe communiste républicain et citoyen
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cette
question de l'application du gel de la
réglementation surtout en direction des
entreprises posés par la circulaire du
17 juillet 2013 prolonge le débat que
nous avons eu il y à peu dans cet
hémicycle sur le conseil d'évaluation
des normes
à cet égard je partage les propos de ma
collègue cécile cukierman malgré le flot
de critiques la prolifération normative
une insécurité juridique qui en
résultent s'accentue entre autres avec
le projet de loi macron près 300
articles nous sont présentés en urgence
de surcroît pour faire moins de neuf
faisons plus de normes
en somme nous ne pensons d'ailleurs pas
que cette inflation normative soit dû
aux ailes normative des administrations
de l'état aussi bien centrale que
déconcentrer c'est une vision
caricaturale qui minimisent l'exigence
de clarté du droit inscrit dans la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
en réalité il n'ya pas de volonté
perverse de quelques administrateurs
mais une volonté de produire la norme la
meilleure au service de la sécurité
juridique
d'ailleurs un rapport d'information de
la commission des lois d'avril dernier
intitulé le droit des entreprises enjeu
d'attractivité internationale précise je
cite que la situation des entreprises
françaises n'est pas préoccupante du
point de vue du droit qui leur est
applicable
en réalité il est délicat de concilier
simplification administrative et
légitimité de l'action publique au
service d'une société solidaire et de
progrès si la norme peut être
contraignante en effet à l'égard de
certains à plus long terme un nom
protège d'autres derrière le leitmotiv
de la simplification ne se cache-t-il
pas une volonté pure et simple de
dérégulation nous ne nions pas les
difficultés rencontrées par nos
entreprises n'ouvriront rappeler que
cette exacerbation est d'ailleurs en
partie liée à l'insuffisance des moyens
financiers au service des pme d'été peut
qu'elle est liée au retrait de l'état et
la diminution du nombre de
fonctionnaires en particulier les
restructurations de services
administratifs s'intensifiant par la
réduction des personnels de la fonction
publique les mutualisations des
privatisation larvée de service
public quant à la dérégulation et au
moyen et au moins d'état qui se profile
souvent derrière une démarche de
simplification
la circulaire du 17 juillet 2013
n'échappe pas à la règle et dispose que
tout nouveaux textes réglementaires
créant des charges pour les
collectivités les entreprises aux le
public ne pourra être adapté que s'il
s'accompagne à titre de gage d'une
simplification équivalente
revenons un peu sur ce sujet selon le
vocabulaire même de la circulaire les
normes juridiques administratives et
techniques sont donc considérés comme de
simples marchandises dont il faudrait
vérifier les volumes peser les pois
évaluer les validité jusqu'à signifier
les dates de près péremption de
préemption pour reprendre les termes
d'ailleurs bull professeur madame koubbi
c'est là où nous pensons qu'il faut être
vigilant car selon la circulaire toute
réglementation nouvelle doit désormais
contribuer positivement à l'effort de
simplification du droit est ce ainsi
véritablement qu'on relancera les
entreprises au plus tôt en favorisant
leur carnet de commandes de plus
toujours sur la selon la circulaire il
importe que l'évaluation financière soit
correctement renseigné il s'agisse des
charges significatives créé par la
réglementation dire allègements qui sont
réimporter or ce qui est perçu comme
complexité par les gouvernements
successifs suffit d'ailleurs d'entendre
ici certains orateurs c'est le droit au
travail le droit fiscal et plus
largement les droits emprunt n'est
certaine justice sociale à cet égard le
rapport de jeu dont je vous faisais part
est particulièrement éclairant puisque
les mesures de complexité évoqué son
l'obligation d'informer préalablement
les salariés en cas de cession de leur
entreprise en vue leur permettent de
présenter une offre de reprise sous
peine d'annulation de la session ou
encore la mise en place de la procédure
d'action groupe en matière de
consommation de concurrence qui
demanderont et cela est normal
une réglementation pour leur mise en
oeuvre est effectif enfin la mise au
point de cette politique de
simplification dépendrait selon la
circulaire de méthodes de
consultation participative si l'idée la
participation doit effectivement être
encouragée nous devons garder à l'esprit
que c'est le législateur et le
gouvernement qui ont en charge la
définition l'intérêt général et ce
dernier ne peut être la somme des
intérêts particuliers aussi légitime
soit-il
de plus il ne faudrait pas sous-estimer
les limites de l'évaluation économique
systématiques du droit
or c'est bien ces termes que la
circulaire du 17 juillet envisage la
simplification normative donc en guise
de conclusion je voudrais rappeler que
le nombre de normes risque de croître
et oui en effet les citoyens les
entreprises attendent toujours plus de
sécurité c'est bien normal
cette demande est relayée par les médias
et les pouvoirs publics
ils répondent forcément par l'adoption
de normes de plus comme le soulignait le
conseil d'état
la multiplication des sources externes
le droit européen en particulier en même
temps que l'apparition de nouveaux
domaines sont facteurs de la complexité
croissante du droit
citons la progression de père d'ailleurs
avec la libéralisation économique de la
régulation par des autorités
administratives de pans entiers du droit
le droit boursier là et même le droit de
l'énergie ces rôles droit des
télécommunications l'arcep
l'informatique et libertés la semil il y
à aussi l'apparition de nouveaux
domaines de législations complexes comme
le droit la concurrent de la concurrence
le droit monétaires et financiers dans
un contexte sous verre ou encore les bio
te le dis aux technologies qui
accompagne de fait il faut le dire une
logique de libéralisation ce débat donc
nous avons aujourd'hui nous le disons
fortement n'est pas neutre politiquement
dans tous les cas mes chers collègues
nous devons veiller à ce que
l'évaluation qualitative l'emportent sur
une évaluation qui serait au final fils
faussement comptable
merci cher collègue monsieur yvon collin
à la parole pour le groupe rdse
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
prolifération des normes
la multiplication de leurs sources sont
un sujet récurrent dans la phrase source
souffre d'un harcèlement textuel bien
ancrée le forum économique mondial sur
la compétitivité des économies place la
france à la 130e place en matière de
poids de la réglementation ne peut pas
être bon partout certes mais la 130ème
c'est pas très glorieux dans son rapport
sur la simplification de
l'administration française publié en
2004 le cda a souligné que le coot de la
paperasserie s'élever en moyenne à 11%
du pib selon le standard que ce modèle
trop souvent les entreprises doivent
faire face à de nouvelles normes
prescrites par l'état d'une part klaus
qu'il exerce son pouvoir réglementaire
et d'autre part lorsqu'il applique tout
simplement l'amour
elles doivent assimiler ces entreprises
environ 3000 nouvelles informations
chaque année et ainsi faire face à de
lourdes procédures administratives qui
entrave leur développement
régulièrement les entreprises doivent
communiquer leurs chiffres d'affaires le
respect des normes environnementales des
mesures paritaires sans que les
différentes administrations soient
toujours lui en mesure de croiser et
donc de coordonner les informations qui
ont déjà été transmises à cela
s'ajoutent des normes européennes dont
nous mesurons parfois sur le terrain la
contrainte qu'elles peuvent générer pour
les acteurs économiques 5e soit toujours
démontré leur utilité de la taille des
cages pour palm était palmipèdes gras
aux calibres des bananes déterminé je
cite c'est un peu érotique par la
longueur du fruit exprimés 1 cm et
mesurer le long de la phase complexe
depuis le point d'insertion du pédoncule
sur le coup signer jusqu'à la paix''
on atteint souvent des précisions
décourageante pour les agriculteurs qui
comme tout entrepreneur aspirent
nous le savons à la simplification à ce
niveau plus qu'un ne réglemente
l'administration tourmente
c'est pourquoi il ya urgence à agir pour
simplifier la vie des entreprises d
exploitation et d industrie
c'est en particulier vitale pour les
petites entités pour lesquels le coot
des formalités administratives est
beaucoup plus lourd
faute des ressources humaines
suffisantes pour les gérer le temps que
consacre ses dirigeants d'entreprises à
mettre en application les normes est
autant d'énergie perdue qu'il pourrait
employer à stratégie de développement
mes chers collègues il faut reconnaître
que les gouvernements qui se sont
succédé depuis deux décennies ont tenté
de résoudre cette problématique même si
l'incantation a souvent pris le pas sur
l'action dès son arrivée au pouvoir le
président hollande a décidé un choc de
simplification la création l'année
dernière du conseil de la simplification
pour les entreprises et le témoin
concret de cette volonté de desserrer
l'étau réglementaires qui pèsent sur les
entreprises et in fine et finalement
nuit on nous le savons à l'emploi je me
réjouis monsieur le ministre également
des annonces faites hier par le premier
ministre visant à alléger certaines
formalités pour les tpe et pme
je pense en particulier à la
simplification à l'accès aux aides
publiques ou encore au développement du
titre emploi service entreprise dans le
projet de loi pour la croissance et
l'activité il ya aussi des mesures
intéressantes monsieur le ministre que
nous avons approuvées notamment la mise
en place d'un identifiant électronique
unique et sécurisé pour les entreprises
et l'allègement des obligations
comptables pour les tpe durant leur
période d'inactivité
tout cela bien sûr va dans le bon sens
nous en donne acte mais cela ne résout
pas la question du stock fossilisés de
normes et de règles qui se sont
accumulés c'est pourquoi monsieur le
ministre vous allez sans d'autres nous
éclairer
sur le bilan de la circulaire du 17
juillet 2013 relative à la mise en
oeuvre du gel de la réglementation des
entreprises qui prévoient notamment une
norme créer une norme supprimer ou aller
chez car comme l'indiquent notre
excellente collègues elisabeth lamure
dans le texte de sa question orale la
simplification réglementaire est un
enjeu de compétitivité et de croissance
j'ajouterai que c'est aussi un enjeu
d'attractivité internationale comme j'ai
dit au début de mon intervention l'état
de ce ministre une responsabilité dans
la production de normes
on doit donc s'interroger sur la façon
de ralentir cette inflation
certes il ya la circulaire précité qui
pose une règle si je puis dire des
inflationniste mais il faut aussi
s'attaquer au processus de production de
la norme est à cet égard je relèverai un
extrait du fameux rapport lambert
boulard qui souligne que pour chaque
question pour chaque problème
la réponse a été trop souvent
l'instauration d'une nouvelle loi d'une
loi nouvelle plutôt que la recherche
d'une action plus efficace dans le cadre
de lois existantes
le législateur est en effet également
comptable nous la voix de l'empilement
normatif certes nous avons désormais et
loi de simplification mais c'est un peu
le serpent qui se mord la queue
il faut une norme pour abroger le nombre
n'est ce pas alors l'état d'esprit de
l'état qu'il faudrait faire évoluer
il faudrait en effet trouver le point
d'équilibré entre colbert et tocqueville
entre une société encadré pour mieux la
protéger
une société responsabiliser pour
encourager soldano son dynamisme et la
liberté d'entreprendre dans le contexte
économique actuel sommes d'accord pour
tous dire qu'il est difficile nos chefs
d'entreprise ont besoin de stabilité de
visibilité et surtout pas de coûts
induits par un excès de normes
c'est pourquoi monsieur le ministre vert
dès ce vous encourage à ne pas relâcher
les efforts vaste chantier qu'est le
défrichage normatif
nous vous faisons comme ça pour vous y
atteler et vous remercie de votre
attention mesdames et mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
devraient commencer ce propos en vous
disant combien je trouve que le débat
qui nous réunit cet après midi d'abord a
été riche très précis pas dogmatique et
j'en félicite l'ensemble des membres de
cette assemblée va me permettre de
clarifier un certain nombre de deux
points qui méritent de l'être de donner
les informations à cette assemblée
mais plus généralement peut-être si vous
le souhaitez et notamment vous madame la
présidente d'engager avec vous un
travail dans les mois qui viennent qui
nous permette d'aller encore plus loin
plus vite plus fort en matière de
simplification des règles concernant la
vie économique sachant que comme vous je
crois que il en va de la compétitivité
de nos entreprises
il en va de l'équité dans la vie
économique entre les petites entreprises
qui n'ont aucun moyen pour affronter la
complexité qui subissent de plein fouet
l'ensemble des normes et des grandes
entreprises qui finalement s'y habitue
voire même parce qu'elles ont les outils
les moyens les conseils pour y faire
face en tire des avantages
concurrentiels
il en va donc d'une certaine conception
de la vie économique et des règles de
concurrence qui doivent être loyal l'un
d'entre vous tout à leur site et
tocqueville
en vous écoutant me revenait à l'esprit
la phrase de tocqueville qui dit qu'il
ya beaucoup plus de lumière et de
sagesse dans beaucoup d'hommes réunis
dans un seul vous en avez fait la
démonstration pourrait corriger tous
vivre regrettons qu'il n'est pas diplômé
tram puisque ce débat c'est le débat que
vous avez vous lu madame la présidente
deux mots d'abord pour bien sûr et pour
l'occasion vous est posée mais plus
généralement l'ensemble des
problématiques de simplification puisque
le débat était beaucoup plus large que
la circulaire du 17 juillet 2013 que ces
débats ont concerné à la fois les stocks
de mesures existantes mais aussi le flux
tout ce qui vient s'ajouter à des
volumes de complexité qui sont
importants et pour appeler finalement
que les politiques de simplification
sont pas nouvelles préparant ce ce débat
je lisais que dès le 26 septembre 53 un
décret reconnaissait la nécessité de
simplifier les formalités
administratives en 83 a été créé une
commission pour la simplification des
formalités incombant aux entreprises et
je ne vais pas vous donner toute la
chronologie chronologie ça fait très
longtemps qu'on en parle
ça fait très longtemps qu objectivement
personne ne voit les résultats concrets
des politiques de simplification et
c'est finalement instruit de ce paradoxe
des efforts renouvelés depuis très
longtemps et des effets assez faible que
quand nous avons été amenés j'ai été
amené à m'intéresser à ces questions
c'était à l'époque à la demande du
premier ministre et de jean marc ayrault
et du président de la république
la première chose que j'ai fait c'est
finalement de faire ce que vous avez
fait il ya peu de temps un tour d'europe
des pays qui eux mènent depuis quelques
années un peu moins de 10 ans pour la
plupart d'entre des politiques de
simplification avec des résultats plus
ou moins grands selon leur propre regard
mais ce qui surtout ont mis en place des
outils des méthodes pour réussir la
simplification en direction de la vie
économique
donc on est allé regarder ce qui se
passait à l'étranger vous avez cité
l'allemagne avec le nordmann contrôle
raté d'autres dispositifs vous ai cités
l'angleterre on est allé en belgique aux
pays-bas en dan lo danemark pas la liste
intégrale mais nous avons commencé
sagement et j'allais dire modestement à
regarder comment il fallait s'y prendre
pour réussir une politique de
simplification de ce petit tour d'europe
nous avons tiré quelques principes qui
fondent la politique dont nous allons
parler pendant les quelques minutes que
vous avez bien voulu m'accorder le
premier le plus important c'est que
cette politique est d'ailleurs vous
l'illustré vous même en visitant les
entreprises au sein de votre commission
votre délégation
elle ne peut être que collaborative la
politique de simplification ne peut pas
être décidé par les administrations
ce n'est pas à elle de faire ce qui les
arrange
en considérant que c'est ça la
simplification la politique de
simplification elle pas de la complexité
vécue par les entreprises et de cible de
complexité qu'elle-même désigne auxquels
il faut s'attaquer parce que c'est ce
qui pollue leur vie quotidienne
ce travail se fait au sein de sous que
vous avez la plupart d'entre vous nommé
le conseil de la simplification qui
n'est finalement qu'une fabrique à
simplifier réunissant une
un peu plus d'une centaine d'entreprises
en ateliers réguliers autour de 10
moments clés de la vie de l'entreprise
la création de l'entreprise la
déclaration fiscale et sociale
le recrutement l'import-export je ne
sais pas tout la liste de ces groupes de
travail et hot dans ses ateliers
composés de grandes de petites
entreprises est d'ailleurs plutôt des
niveaux hiérarchiques en butte avec la
complexité pas forcément du président de
la société ou de la présidente de la
société
le comptable quand il s'agit des
réparations fiscales et sociales le la
poule le responsable quand il y en a
dans des ressources humaines quand il
s'agit du recrutement de la formation
par exemple dans ses ateliers
dans un premier temps c'est d'abord ce
qui est vraiment vécu comme les
problèmes à traiter par les entreprises
et ensuite un travail avec
l'administration qui permet deuxième
élément de la méthode de près instruire
toutes les mesures que nous annonçons
avant même qu'elle soit qu'elles aient
un statut de plan d'action ou de
propositions ou de mesures annoncées
c'est à dire qu'il ya tout un travail
que fait le conseil de simplification de
préparation des décisions et de
préparation collaborative là encore en
vérifiant que les décisions que nous
allons prendre correspond bien à ce que
les entreprises veulent mais aussi que
les conséquences des mesures éventuelles
que nous allons prendre de
simplification sont bien celles qui vont
simplifier vraiment la vie des
entreprises
je dis cela parce que derrière cette
c'est ce travail préalable annonce des
mesures il y a je crois une entre
guillemets mini révolution en tout cas
une façon nouvelle de produire de la
note de la norme 6 résume et c'est vrai
pour tout le monde pour nous aujourd'hui
comme pour les gouvernements qui nous
ont précédés si je résume aujourd'hui la
culture de fabrique de la norme
française
c'est une culture qui décide
guînes orientations qu'elle juge bonnes
pour le pays pour les entreprises et
puis une fois que cette norme est
décidée qui découvre bien souvent des
effets
pervers ou inattendu dans la mise en
oeuvre qui font que soit au mieux la
mesure s'applique mais elle produit pas
tout à fait les résultats comptent
ce contest soit au pire on peut pas
l'appliquer et vous avez cité la
question de la pénibilité pour avoir
plusieurs fois exprimé le propos que je
tiens ici je considère qu'on a bien fait
voter un texte que les assemblées auront
voté un texte relatif à la pénibilité au
passage dispositifs qui existent dans
l'ensemble des pays européens ou presque
mais que le texte initial qui avait été
voté par le parlement était un texte qui
était parfait mais il veut pas
s'impliquer et que donc nous avons
travaillé à le simplifier et donc
deuxième élément de la méthode après
d'année voilà pour ce débat qui s'est
tenu tout à l'heure dans les mystiques à
la demande de la délégation sénatoriale
aux entreprises un débat qui a porté sur
les normes qui pèse l'excès de normes
qui pèsent sur les tpe pme très petites
petites et moyennes entreprises qui vous
le savez centre au coeur actuellement de
la réflexion du gouvernement
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les séances sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr à 19h ne manquaient pas à
vingt-quatre heures sénat le journal
présenté par delphine girard très bonne
fin de journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires